i would love to be a fly on that wall i
would love to just shadow you like a
ghost all day because that sounds like
my dream come true
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the
unwaxed podcast with your favorite
sisters sophia and sistine
stalane
good morning that was horrible look at
the peppa what did you say
she tried it
stop she learned to tell what did you
use duolingo i okay i tried it was my
quarantine thing i said i'm gonna learn
italian so every day i did two hours and
i lost it a month
pretty good she's basically for me
pretty good but i only remember one
thing what yeah i mean you just said
like three different things i think
those were cuss words though what did i
remember it was something like
um
no one come for me right now if it's
wrong it's something like
and what does that mean i would like to
drink wine at your place of course
that's the one thing she remembers is
alcohol but i'm pretty sure i mix
spanish in there anyway um ho ho ho
happy holiday you little [ __ ] elves
just kidding um fat santas
stockings are getting stuffed oh my god
you're on a level right now it's really
early
it is not really early but we're really
happy to have you guys on here um it's
holiday season you guys are probably
hitting a ton of holiday parties and
what's better than a holiday party i
mean i don't love to throw them but i
love to go to them drink some eggnog
spiked eggnog what else do we love hot
totties mold wine can i
shout out sly yeah actually i was sick a
few weeks ago he makes a delicious hot
toddy now at the time
at the time he told me he was just
making me hot tea
and i couldn't taste anything because i
was sick
not covered i was just sick and um i
started to get a little buzzed i'm like
drunk on my 8th tea i go sly what's
what's in these he's like whiskey okay
what okay i gotta drive
she goes to restaurants and says do you
know how to make a hot toddy and they go
yeah i have not heard anybody ask that
baby i feel like bartenders hate me now
because they're like really i gotta make
hot drinks but it actually
it does take time like it is like a
process to do i try to make it it's not
as easy as it looks
i'm really stressed about holiday
shopping because
i feel like i ran out of ideas for you
guys three years ago
um
yeah i actually i haven't because i once
again love experiences not things so i'm
trying to think of what would sistine
love to do
and so i think that's more of a fun
thing because the scene is really good
at gifts so to find something specific
for all of us is pretty uh
like what else do you get someone i have
to say the gift
did you get it for me or scarlet got it
for me you guys got me
two tickets to ratatouille the musical
oh that was scarlet and guess what by
the way
it's called the ratatouille the the best
part about this the best part about the
one is that scarlett deleted the email i
lost the tickets
i didn't even get to see it i just told
sistine you're going to the ratatouille
whatever it's called
and she couldn't go
do you want to hear something crazy sure
so um
this guy that i was with the other night
you mean your boyfriend sophia we
haven't exposed that yet on the podcast
but yeah i guess it's out
she's
not single
you know what it's cuffing season and i
thought
i'm definitely going to be cold i'm
always cold might as well need
you know yeah a man to spoon oh it's
going to warm me up i hated that anyway
point being he said
i really feel like watching ratatouille
right now
and i said get on any
let's get married
you're the one for me
that's the best movie ever see it really
is not the best movie ever name a better
pixar movie
um the incredibles no no not girls is it
incredible
what is it
wait no i meant monsters inc i meant
monsters inc still not as good
oh i do have to say monsters university
kind of good it kind of slaps i mean
like i can watch it 12 times a day but
wait oh sorry really fast what tell me
right now monsters university has the
same energy as 22 jump street
wow
right
uh mike wazowski and sully
channing tatum is sully and then jonah
hill's mike wazowski
do they do a live version kind of right
do they do a live version
sorry what were
i'd like to speak to universal i need to
speak to hollywood
why do i find that funny so she said she
had a man guys
i have a date
okay
y'all like i don't go on enough except
this is a date that
i'm not exactly thrilled that you're
going on well i think by this point i
think the date would have ended so
we're either gonna be super elated after
this week or we're gonna be super
annoyed that she even put hair rollers
in i really hope future you is elated
i don't
do you think the man i'm going on a date
with is gonna make me feel elated no
because the first time you went on the
date with him you hated it
yes that's fair that is fair uh and i
think i just kind of wanted to see no
well do you guys believe in that do you
believe if a first date goes really bad
that they deserve a second one like what
are the thoughts studio audience yes or
no nodding heads
not a deal breaker so something really
bad would have to happen if you were
like no he's nice we'll see how it goes
um
yeah it didn't hit the first time we got
along but we'll see how it why didn't it
hit the first time
i oh it was just like there's little
things that were said here and there
that i was like um i don't know but
overall we did kind of have a connection
so i'm not totally hopeless about i
i'm just you know we're we're gonna see
what i can just
pull from this date so we were having
this big debate um right before you got
into the studio today because you were
late i wasn't late anyway it wasn't late
we were talking about uh the best burger
in la yeah and
the producers and myself agreed that
shake shack was far more superior than
in and out do you guys actually agree
with that
they're all nodding their head yeah are
you [ __ ] me
shake shack is better than in and out
now sophia i would like to read you
something on the internet and maybe
it'll change your mind
what you tell me what in and out
has a meet grade
of f
for fail that's not true
the vast majority of hamburger chains 22
of the 25 including giants such as
mcdonald's and in and out got an f grade
because they lack established policies
restricting antibiotic use in their beef
supply chains whatever that means but
it's still enough you're probably eating
a rat are you serious what are you
eating i'm just kidding
i don't know i'm crying
oh wait that actually is really
disappointing i know i know
in and out are you kidding me
i vouched for you i
every debate
i went in hard for you and now you got
an f
have you ever failed anything before yes
i got a c in calculus that's not a fail
let's see
a c in calculus i feel yeah i can't uh
wakeboard i'm a horrible wakeboarder i
can't have you failed to test before
yeah a lot i felt so many tests and i
forged
uh dad's signature so that the teacher
didn't have to see it so we did that in
middle school so basically what would
happen is if you failed to test uh
your parent would have to sign a paper
and like show that they saw that you
failed the test you have to show your
teacher and then you put in the thing so
what i did was i told my dad to sign
this like
uh retreat form that i was going on and
i caught i grabbed some tracing paper
and i practiced over and over and over
one time and i figured it out one time i
did something so stupid and it still is
traumatizing to this day
i failed a spelling test and i got every
single one wrong
and i thought if i used white out
on all of the red markings
that mom wouldn't notice
the entire page was covered in white out
paint
and then i even
like put a plus on it mom thought it was
so funny that she took it to her dinner
party that they were having at the house
and all of the women and all of the
couples were just this they're cackling
and i was standing there crying with
like my hands in the arthur fist like
stop making fun of me oh god yeah that's
funny i did fail my ap biology test
the first one
yeah are you going to continue with that
or you want do you have anything else to
say she says oh no i was thinking about
mom for a second i thought about what
i'm going to get her for christmas and
i'm freaking out
you know what is a great gift though
what to give people what
manscaped
you
did it
sophia
yes
finally with the smooth manscape
it was pretty it was pretty um it was a
little rough a little bit i'd give that
but you know
what was rough
your mouth
that you haven't shaved with manscaped
[Laughter]
santa baby it's holiday season and you
don't know what to get a gift as a
stocking stuffer huh well today's
sponsor manscaped
has the tool that guarantees you a win
for this year's stocking stuffer
competition damn manscaped you guys has
changed more than four million men
worldwide for the better in my opinion
if my math is correct
it's almost uh
eight million balls manscape's
best-selling product is the performance
package 4.0 which is at the top of every
man's wish
nothing is sexier than a smooth ornament
if you know what i mean guys i know what
you mean inside you'll find their
lawnmower body trimmer the best trimmer
on the market for balls back chest i
mean whatever you want to trim it'll
work and the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer let's not forget the famous
liquid formulations the crop preserver
ball deodorant and crop reviver the ball
toner to keep him smelling nice down
below that's my favorite ladies listen
up this is the perfect gift for you and
your man and trust me he will thank you
now these are our picks for manscape's
surefire wind stocking stuffers number
one
the manscaped two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner
it just launched you guys and it's about
time he stops stealing yours the
manscaped cologne body infused body wash
ladies you may want to borrow this one
too it's true it does smell really good
three shears 2.0 luxury four piece nail
kit and what do we say a red flag bad
nail care
not for us number four the crop mops the
ball wipes the go-to solution for stinky
balls
and number five manscape's signature
cologne
it is sexy yet delightful these
formulations are all vegan cruelty free
dye free soul freight free paraben free
so you know his cojones are in great
hands okay you guys so make sure you go
to their site to ensure that these wild
gifts show up before the holiday season
whether this is for your partner your
dad your brother your friend the
neighbor your dog
get them something that they will
actually use and it's almost sure to get
a laugh get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com using the code on wax
cheers to rocking the best gifts of this
holiday season it's a gift for him but
ladies it's also a gift for you
xoxo landscapes
okay you guys today we have on the
creator of fleur de mau the first luxury
brand to introduce lingerie in a way
that is both wearable yet stylishly
provocative this brand is a go-to
favorite for hollywood celebrities such
as kylie jenner margot robbie ariana
grande and the list goes on we are so
excited to have on jennifer zuccherini
hi jennifer i've been such a fan of this
brand since i was probably 16 years old
and the career and the path that you
have built and the message that you're
spreading through your brand is
something that i hope to emulate myself
one day so we're really excited to have
you on i'm so flattered to hear that
thank you i'm so excited to be i guess
on the show
um i was just listening
to your show on my way i was at a photo
shoot in brooklyn and then um came home
to do the podcast and i'm a big fan
of both of you so that is the chicest
thing i've ever seen
what was the photo shoot for uh shooting
our pre-fall collection oh my god so our
lookbook um yeah so we were just on a
shoot and then i raced back home and
happy to now be here with you guys oh my
gosh i love it well i would love to sort
of
get into how you began with florida mall
your career even before that sort of
just walk us through the whole process
of how you started and how you ended up
now well i always knew i wanted to be in
fashion from when i was probably
eight or nine years old um so that was
something
you know i actually took sewing lessons
when i was eight
um i was sketching so i knew from a
really young age i read every fashion
magazine i was like very into everything
everything fashion and then
i ended up i moved to new york and went
to fit to study fashion design
and um always i always wanted to start
my own
brand that's something you know i never
really thought about doing anything else
um but when i first graduated i worked
for some designers in new york just to
get some experience and then i ended up
co-founding
another company i don't know if you guys
are familiar with it um kiki de mont
pranasis yes
yes which was like a very high-end
kind of everything to enhance your
intimate life
luxury concepts right um so i did that
and that was really my first experience
building a brand from scratch and that's
something i just
i love doing not just designing the
product but also just thinking about how
people interact with the brand and that
emotional connection you have you know
when you love when you're like oh i
really just want i want to wear that i
want people to know that's what i'm
wearing i did that for a few years and
then actually i did i worked for
victoria's secret for a couple of years
um i kind of fell into lingerie that
wasn't ever what i thought i was going
to be doing i thought i would design
just
ready to wear fashion i personally love
lingerie i used to get so excited about
yeah and so do we we i mean
especially we just think it's the
coolest thing even just to wear under
clothes that are your day-to-day clothes
just so you have like this little secret
that's sexy and makes you feel
comfortable honestly i spent all of my
money on lingerie and it's my favorite
part about it is that
it's i don't wear it for other people i
wear it for myself
so i love everything you're saying right
now was there something about lingerie
that you were thinking okay this is
something i want to dive into because it
was untapped or because it was something
that people didn't really understand
because i think the laundry like for me
a lot of my girlfriends for their
birthdays i always like to buy them
something that's a bit more proactive
sometimes i'll buy them a vibrator
sometimes i'll buy them lingerie
something that they wouldn't normally
buy for themselves was that something
that you wanted to target because it's
something that people probably don't
they're not very knowledged in yeah
originally when i started i was thinking
um i loved personally wearing beautiful
lingerie that was also
maybe you know i i felt like the market
was either very sexy and a little maybe
borderline trashy or super super basic
and i was really thinking about how i
like to dress and how my friends like to
dress and
being able to wear something beautiful
under your clothing every day that isn't
so like
has so much going on that you can't
actually wear it yeah exactly and really
taking more of a in a way a fashion
approach to lingerie and incorporating
you know thinking about how our girl
dresses
wearing you know whether it's like bra
tops or body suits or layering you know
boost days under jackets so really kind
of bringing that fashion element to
lingerie i didn't really feel like
anyone was doing that and we started you
know not just with lingerie but also
with all those categories slip dresses
bodysuits
um so i really felt there was
something missing in the market and we
try to do things that are also at a more
attainable price point
and really thinking about covering our
woman for every moment of her life and
um but to your point
you know it's it's thinking about how it
makes you feel our customer is buying
because she wants to feel amazing it's
not necessarily about anyone else
seeing it right well i would love to tap
into that sort of embracing your
femininity because
i think that is again like sophia said
something that we don't often do and
there's sort of shame and lingerie or
sometimes there's like a trashy
sort of reputation that comes with
wearing it but really i feel like fleur
de maul is completely changing
the way people are wearing it and
approaching it and i would love to sort
of hear from you like
exploring your feminine side sexual side
how is this important to you and how is
it sort of changing as the brand is
constantly evolving when a woman is
powerful
um sometimes that doesn't always
connect with
someone being also embracing their
sexuality
so i think for a man when you think
about a powerful man that's also sexy i
mean everybody loves that right nobody
questions that right it just makes it
that much exactly but i always i always
feel like for women in a way to be taken
seriously almost you almost have to
suppress that part of you a little bit
yes and i felt you know why can't a
woman really bring those two sides
together and be comfortable with i'm i'm
a woman i love being a woman i love
i'm a sexual person right um that
doesn't have to be
that doesn't have to be separate from
also being
a badass powerful woman in your everyday
life and actually that's something that
you said that because we i wrote
something down about being a woman in
business and especially now you're in
the lingerie business i mean did you
ever have people while you were growing
your business
ever doubt you and say something going
okay she's not professional enough
because she's doing this or what were
the things that were almost setbacks for
you but maybe something that fueled you
forward i think when you're a designer
or you're a creative person um and you
guys are creators and you have a
business your partner plus everything
else you're doing i think people
they always want to know well who's your
partner who are you doing this with like
i think they that becomes more of a
question for a woman than it ever does
for a man
um and i didn't i didn't have a partner
um and they want to know people when
you're pitching to investors who
oh so you're the creative part
got that who who's the business side of
it like
and i would say well i have a lot of
advisors i'm you know people on my team
um i don't think you know
there's it's wonderful to have a partner
and i think that's a great model for a
lot of people but also
for some you know maybe you hire the
people that you need
and i think for a woman that was a
question that came up a lot being more
of a creative person and being a woman
that maybe there was something missing
without having that other person on my
team with me did you find that because
all of these people were doubting you
and like that's something sophie and i
constantly struggle with
um because of who our dad is people
always think oh well you're getting this
because of that or if i go in to pitch
something no one will take me seriously
because they're thinking okay she's just
23 what credibility does she have to
sell us anything but did you ever tell
yourself something or did you have a
change of mind
yeah a change of mindset that sort of
kind of led you forward and and yeah
continue to push forward because
sometimes that's hard constantly feeling
enjoying i feel like people in business
are successful they have something that
switches in them that goes we i can do
it like all the other barriers between
them is relevant i think it's really
that perseverance and you know i never
gave up and i went through so many hard
times and you have to have that
that drive to say no matter no matter
what's happening and if you even if
people are telling you no that you're
just going to keep hitting it every day
and i put in the hours i put in the time
i didn't i didn't give up and there were
many many moments where
i didn't know if we were going to make
it in the early years because it's also
such a cash intensive yeah business
right um
and and i didn't know and i
luckily had people around me friends and
mentors that that were like you're gonna
get through this like you just this
happens this happens to everybody like
we've i've been through what you're
going through and you just need to
stick it out right and and
i'm so thankful that i i didn't give up
but i think um
being on yeah
i mean
doing anything in entertainment fashion
you
come up against a lot of no's and a lot
of people are probably telling you
i don't believe in what you're doing but
um
you just need to find the people that do
believe in you and if you have
a strong concept you'll you'll find
those people
um i luckily also i felt you know
in a business setting i'm very
professional and i think when you
conduct yourself that way people
are that way back i mean i know some
women friends of mine who pitched to a
lot of male investors and felt like
maybe that
those investors were making like hitting
on them or making them feel
uncomfortable and i've had that happen a
couple of times but
honestly most of the time i think if
you're a professional and you know your
[ __ ] you know your stuff then people
treat you that way i think that is
wonderful advice um for someone like me
who again like loves the the career and
the path that you've made for yourself
what would be a good first step even for
me or someone that isn't wanting to be
in the lingerie business but a woman
trying to build her own business
what would you recommend would be a
great first step for them starting with
a business plan um
is the most important thing to do
because
it helps you gather your thoughts like
is this really what am i trying to do
what is my point of view why is this
needed in the world whatever that may be
any business any even you know even a
podcast even yeah um so it's not the
maybe the most fun thing to start with
but that's how i started
and
it it it gives you a discipline to say
well
i need to work out how much money i'm
gonna need to launch this what is my
what is my three year plan
and what is the mission statement why
you know how am i going to make this
business work who am i going to get
involved what's my team going to look
like when am i going to hire them it
just forces you
to ask yourself a lot of questions
um that you'll need to do anyway and
through that process you might say
oh i i didn't realize i was gonna have
to do all this i need to change
pivot my idea a little or do something
different so
that i would recommend as a always the
best first step right all right i'll
start drafting something up right after
this call
i'm on it you know i i actually i always
think about this is when you said that
you've always wanted to do fashion i
find that
so incredible because i think a lot of
people especially like i mean for me
personally i know that
yeah i'm still in my 20s it's hard for
me almost to say like what is my purpose
what is my passion what is like i i'm a
big believer that i want to find like
the meaning of why i'm supposed to be
here or like find something that will
get me up in the morning every single
day and you said it was always fashion
for you uh growing up was that something
that you've always just been interested
in like where you raised around a family
that was interested in fashion were you
just kind of the one that randomly was
the fashionista of the family because i
know sistine was always the one that was
the fashionable person in our group and
my mom too but was that something for
you like how did you hit that point
where you were like this is what i need
to be doing
i think my mom was very into fashion and
she would
you know even when i was so young let me
dress myself i always had a desire to
you know pick out my own clothing to
look at every fashion magazine watch
every
fashion
tv show that used to be out back then um
and i think it just
i don't know there was it was something
that just felt so natural for me and i
was into clothing and
growing up
as a teenager like love dressing up and
going out um
but then after a while you know because
everyone expected me to be
going into fashion at some point i
decided i didn't want to do that anymore
and i
i went down more of an art path and i
wanted to
potentially become an art dealer i
studied art history
you know i thought that's awesome
because i thought you know what do i
love doing and i was like i love
traveling i love art i love throwing
parties
i love you know i love this is you know
when i was like 19 or something right um
why don't i become an art dealer and
i'll travel around the world and
discover artists i mean this is just in
my head what i thought an art dealer did
right at that time you're like no they
don't do anything else but they're like
by the way i was exactly the same way i
took art history in college for a couple
semesters i'm like oh you know actually
this is not what i thought i wanted to
love art but there's so many more things
involving it that you start to realize
oh wait this is probably not what my uh
what i want to do every single day
although i loved i loved it when i
studied it i actually wanted to create
something and build something and that's
really my passion is
not just to be
you know a buyer or a critic or a dealer
but to be the one making something right
and that's that gives me a lot of
satisfaction but back to your point of
feeling what is
your purpose i mean
i i think about that all the time as
well because
it is fashion is such a
you know
we're not i'm not saving lives with what
i'm doing but i hope i hope with what
we're building in the brand that we
bring people
some joy some
right fun like i try to make the brand
very engaging and fun but
i think it's more about the culture you
build
around whatever you're doing and
ultimately what i've learned over the
years your team and how
you know how do people feel
how do you make people feel when you're
around them how is your how are you
inspiring your team
um and that i think makes a big
difference but i still you know i don't
know years from now i might do something
completely different right you know i
think that's a good point to make
because i feel like a lot of people i
mean
a lot of people being me put a lot of
stress on finding that one thing that
will hit when it's so fluid your career
i mean you could wake up the next saying
oh you know what i don't want to be a
designer i want to be a
lion tamer i don't know it's true
something and i think that's the it's um
it's important to note that you have
that mindset you're like okay you know
what if i wake up and i want to do
something else then i do something else
like you're not putting so much emphasis
on
being so specific about what you need to
be doing people especially now in their
early 20s
uh early 30s put so much pressure on
themselves to have their career figured
out right away like sophia and i again
we're constantly questioning are we
doing enough are aren't we doing enough
we should be making more money i mean
there's always that going off in our
head you said that you um wanted to be
an art dealer when you were 19. so at
what age did fleur-de-maul
was birthed when did it begin
um how old were you i was
34
see 34 when i started see i'm like
thinking i need a pot so that's the
thing no but see it's so important to
like note that because i think that
we're so surrounded i think with tick
tock and instagram and all of these
things today and especially when we're
always feeling so much pressure like why
aren't we successful enough right now
why aren't we doing more why don't we uh
making a million dollars by the time
we're 23 like kylie jenner it's just
like it it's just so
incredible that we have these um beliefs
that this could happen yeah and it's so
and i and i felt so my first my first
business
company i started when i was 29 but at
that time i felt old like i was like i
remember being 25 feeling
oh my god i can't believe i haven't made
it yet you know and there's
there is and now it's even so much worse
i mean it's there's so much pressure but
i also felt at some point like and i'm
sure
you guys could think of examples of
people that
blew up at a very young age and then
by the time they were so young still in
their 30s maybe
were past their prime and that happens
in a lot of industries well especially
in entertainment and fashion right um
and so part of me felt like
you know what sometimes
if you want to build a beautiful thing
it takes time and you want to be in the
right stage of your life and you have so
much time ahead of you you might change
careers you might do something great now
and 10 years from now want to do
something completely different and
i think it's important for people to
give themselves that freedom yes to make
that choice really well it is really
well set because i we were even saying
this on our last episode um our dad was
talking about like love and specific by
saying don't chase the clock like don't
chase like this time frame that you need
to be successful and make it by the time
you're 30 or else you're just not going
to and he's like the right time will
come for everything the right time to
find love the right time for your
business to head and it's only if you
let it happen that it will work and i
think that you made such a good note
that you were like okay i was in my 30s
when it hit and it worked and i didn't
put so much pressure on making sure i
was married with children this and this
is there's no bad thing about that by
the way like there's nothing wrong with
getting married earlier later but there
wasn't such a time restraint on finding
it you know was there one point that was
just it could be very specific it could
be nothing it could be huge that was
just so rewarding for you and it was
just such a peak moment
um let me think oh my gosh
you know what i felt like
there were so many moments over the
years that i felt like
you know because you question yourself
and you have doubt and you have
difficult days but then there's always
something that happens that gives you a
positive it's like momentum and you're
like oh this is meant to be because this
happened that happened
we've had amazing people wearing the
brand and i think when we were when i
first launched
to have
somebody
a major major celebrity where the brand
when we were weren't that really well
known
was so
re reassuring because we didn't paint
you know we didn't pay anybody we
weren't we didn't have a public sweden
anyone that was like facilitating that
for us so it was rewarding because we're
like oh that person chose
like we used to do a lot of things for
rihanna we used to do you know we've had
everyone wear the brand
um they chose to wear fleur over
anything because they could yeah they
have access to everything so i think
that's always been a nice thing
opening our stores i think always having
you know a physical
space that embodies the brand and people
come in and they're like oh my god i
love the store and i love being here
that's always like it's nice most of our
90 of our business is online and direct
to consumer so i think having those
moments where you know we're doing a
great event or
we're doing something where we're
actually interacting with our our
audience and our customer that's always
very rewarding for me yeah because you
see it physically
in front of you you're like oh my god
it's actually yeah it's mine it's my
baby that must be so cool what are the
things that you're doing today because
you just brought up that 90 of
the what's being bought is being bought
online which is crazy because that's not
the same as it was 10 years ago and now
everything is e-commerce um so since
there's like all these changing and
there's trends and there's tick tock and
instagram are you completely like
restructuring the way you sell your
products now and like what are you doing
that's different than you did like two
years ago before the pandemic i launched
with um online first so originally we
were only oh you're only online through
our website okay i didn't know that
initially yes yes but then we started
selling to you know we have some
wholesale partners we sold to barney's
and
not a porte but always we've been really
focused on e-commerce
um
i think you know social's so important
and it really has been since we launched
most people discover fleur through
instagram
um
and that hasn't that still hasn't
changed
but i think over the last couple of
years
there's so much um
pressure and opportunity to do more
content yeah
so yeah so we're like we're equally you
know content creators as designers and
brands like
every
you know every photo shoot we're not
it's not even so much about the photos
it's the video and we need to like can
we figure out doing a couple of tick
tocks and
then working with influencers i think
that's the influencer piece was not
nearly
i mean when we launched it wasn't really
even a thing right at all um and now
it's so huge i mean that's how you a lot
of these brands get blown up is if one
influencer just promotes their thing
naturally yeah it becomes like the next
big thing and it's just crazy because
that's even with our podcast i mean a
lot of it like our attraction comes from
i mean other than maybe if we do it
correctly we make funny content on tick
tock but it will be from the guests we
have on and it's just like a total shift
in like okay who do we have on like the
targeting people that we want to see is
that what you did with the photo shoot
that you were at today in brooklyn we do
so we'll do video and then we have
somebody else just doing social video
and then we'll try to squeeze in if we
have time like having we did another
shoot last week and we we planned for
the models to do a few different little
tick tock things oh that's it now we
have to build that all out
what does a day in the life look like
for you because i feel like you're a
very busy woman you said you were just
out of shooting now you're doing a
podcast
walk me through a day in the life
usually i start most mornings i have
some sort of team meeting either i'm
meeting with my design team or i'm
meeting with my marketing team and we're
going through all of our initiatives
right now we're on holiday oh that's so
much fun um ooh holidays i love that we
have so many new things launching and
gifts gifting initiatives and cool um so
we'll talk about right now we're deep
just talking about everything else we're
doing for the rest of the year so we're
planning a little i'm like doing a
little event at our store next week in
la
then we're doing something in our new
york store as a little holiday walk
through
um so i'll do a lot of planning meetings
that will have fittings i have a lot of
you know right now i'm kind of
back and forth from the office and right
now i'm at home but mostly i'm at my
back in my studio so i'll have fittings
so we'll go through we bring in a model
we try everything on we make all the
comments
um i do that with my design team three
times a week four times a week
then we'll you know have photo shoots
maybe there's like social content i feel
like i never make enough time to do my
own social content and that's something
that always gets kind of scary but
i would love to be a fly on that wall i
would love to just shadow you like a
ghost all day because that sounds like
my dream come true but it's true
sometimes you get so wrapped up in and
the business side of things that you're
like oh my god my personal needs some
attention as well do you ever have
enough time for yourself oh it's so hard
i think um
for many years i really didn't make
enough time for myself and i was always
working
every weekend working late at night i
still do there's rarely a weekend that i
don't work for for some of the weekend i
just
i have to do it to kind of just even
just have like a little creative time to
myself where
i don't have any interruptions
um sometimes i just have to do that on
the weekend
but now i'm a little better like
i do you know what's really important to
me is i love seeing my friends my family
i always want to i don't want to
usually cancel on things like that for
work so i try to make that a priority
um in the morning i like to do
i want to do a workout usually i want
maybe do a meditation
um that's i started doing that in the
pandemic
as a wave sorry my dryer is like
different
go and like turn it off um
i started doing that during the pandemic
and that was like a way for me to start
my day
more grounded and feel
have the energy i needed to deal with
everything with
with my wait time so has that changed um
your mindset and the way you do things
daily from meditation okay so i because
i try to do it and i mean cecine you do
it quite well i do it quite well but
it's honestly it's one of those things
that you should be doing it every single
day to get like normalize it and make it
something that's just part of your daily
routine what have you seen in the
differences between then and now from
you doing meditation for years i was the
same i would
always
think i have to start meditating and
when am i going to do that and then once
i started just getting in the habit it's
something i almost look forward to in
the morning it's just i make my coffee
and then i just go and i just do 15
minutes 15 20 minutes max like 15
minutes is pretty that's pretty good no
i'm like five minutes and sometimes i'm
like okay wait
when's the clock gonna go off but that's
bad that means i probably should do it
more often sometimes you wake up and
your mind is racing with i need to do
this or thinking about something you
have you didn't reply to or and it gives
me 15 minutes just to
clear that all away and just reset
and then i just get in touch with i
don't know it's in a way getting in
touch with myself and how i'm feeling
yeah um instead of just being bombarded
with
to do
things yeah more right
it just sort of it's just a cleansing
moment for me and then i always feel
happier i feel happier after yeah
see i hope to get to that level of busy
one day where i'm like actually i need
15 minutes of quiet that's what i'm
emulating that's my goal
um
jennifer you
you are
so amazing and and kind and gracious and
we so appreciate you yeah on the podcast
today i mean all of the advice that you
gave is sort of something i needed to
hear today so i really really appreciate
you coming on it's my pleasure i'm so
happy to be here i love seeing you guys
i'd love to meet in person at some point
i love that thank you you guys are so
you can plug your socials because we
need to hype those up so where can
people find you on instagram and social
media for florence at fleur du mal nyc
um my personal is because i need more
followers also yeah is at jennifer
zuccherini go follow over guys and then
yes and then on tick tock it's the same
it's at flirtable nyc on tick tock and
yeah and we have a store in new york in
a store in l.a oh yeah we're gonna go if
your stocking stuffers are not fleur de
mau i want you to unsubscribe from this
podcast okay
yes jennifer thank you so much we
absolutely love you good luck with
everything in the shoots and the holiday
lookbooks
thank you thank you so much and we'll
send you some we'd love for you guys to
have so close we'll send you some things
pick out some things
have a look
i'm going to send oh send you guys
whatever you want oh don't do it so i'll
have the team follow up oh my god oh god
thank you so much jennifer okay thanks
guys we will see you say bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you